hola a todos estamos en vivo estamos
iniciando nuestro evento en línea el
campeonato que se llama tips y trucos
maestros participando en campeonato esta
vez invitamos a profesores de distintos
contextos educativos que esperemos que
no se enriquezcan con sus comentarios
con todas sus experiencias que han
vivido últimamente entonces pues demos
inicio a nuestro evento y esperemos que
ustedes nos compartan todos sus dudas
inquietudes iniciemos
perfectísimo en la agenda tenemos hoy
como bien lo dice el honor tres
invitados de honor digamos tenemos a
tres profesores de distintas partes de
la república que nos van a estar
compartiendo sus experiencias obtenemos
adriana lara de ciudad de méxico para
que él valdés de honor y por último
vamos a tener también la participación
de adriana flores que también está en
ciudad de méxico
vamos a saber un poquito más de sus
experiencias usando khan academy y
específicamente el campeonato entonces
vamos a saber por qué se decidieron a
participar en el campeonato como se
animaron algo súper importante y que yo
creo que es el coco de todos como
profesores es como me motivan a sus
alumnos para realizar las actividades
pero bueno no todo es miel sobre ojuelas
seguramente se han enfrentado algunos
retos entonces queremos saber cuáles han
sido esos principales retos que han
tenido que vivir con sus con sus
estudiantes
comenzamos con adrián alada adrián es
maestra de inglés historia universal e
historia de mexico en secundaria en el
centro escolar banting en ciudad de
méxico y ella específicamente está
usando las actividades de mentalidad de
crecimiento como ella viene de un área
de humanidades luego es muy común que
nosotros como profesores de sociales y
humanidades digamos uno es que khan
academy es para matemáticas y para
ciencias pero no necesariamente tiene
que ser así entonces le cedemos la
palabra adriana para que nos enriquezca
con su experiencia gracias la obra
bienvenidos a todos los que nos están
viendo que bueno que están interesados
en el campeonato que fue una de las
cosas que me motivó para entrar con los
estudiantes a este reto somos una
escuela que busca la innovación
tecnológica pero no nada más esto sino
que los niños están aprendiendo de otra
forma en las diversas asignaturas lograr
tener una creatividad tanto dentro como
fuera del aula que vean que el
conocimiento se puede compartir en
cualquiera de ámbitos sociales y en este
caso tecnológico es muy importante en
donde se encuentren
que me ayudó y como me está ayudando los
niños lo están viendo como un juego que
realmente ese aprendizaje es un juego y
esto les encanta ellos mismos se están
retando entre ellos a ver quién logra
más actividades que descubrieron en la
plataforma cómo se pueden motivar ellos
para realizar estas actividades que son
cortas en tiempo que les gustan que son
pues otra forma completamente diferente
al paradigma de educación de tener al
docente en frente que simplemente esté
hablando y disque transmitiendo
conocimiento aquí ellos se dan cuenta y
perdón que lo están poniendo en práctica
en estos conocimientos
ha costado trabajo porque bueno nosotros
estamos participando le dije a otros
compañeros que si querían participar y
yo sé que también muchos de nuestros
compañeros docentes son renuentes a
aplicar una nueva forma de enseñanza o
de aprendizaje en nuestro entorno la
situación aquí es que
al ver que los estudiantes estaban
motivando y que no nada más eran
simplemente reproducir aprendizajes
ellos se animaron a entrar a este tipo
de retos por otra parte como estoy
motivando a los alumnos yo sé que en un
primer momento puede ser desde te voy a
cambiar el proyecto tal y vamos a
trabajar con proyectos de khan academy
cuando se dieron cuenta que es muy
sencillo dijeron queremos seguir
trabajando con proyectos de khan academy
mentalidad de crecimiento ha sido para
ellos
como insisto un juego no lo están viendo
como algo extra curiosamente una
experiencia que me pasó en esta semana
fue nosotros tenemos un periodo de
exámenes y les dije esta semana no van a
tener asignados ninguna actividad para
que estudian para sus exámenes
inmediatamente el grupo protestó y dijo
no mix por favor asignan las actividades
qué es lo que nos está gustando
nos estamos apurando en las tareas
escolares para poder hacer nuestras
asignaciones de khan academy lo cual eso
me dio muchísimo gusto guau es está
padrísimo adriana y cómo vas llevando el
control del avance de tus grupos bueno
en la plataforma en un principio uno de
los retos que me costó trabajo fue el
inscribir a mis alumnos porque yo dije
bueno ya con google klaus room y punto
me di cuenta que al tener la plataforma
académica de repente estaba jalando
hasta directivos
entonces si fue de repente frustrante
pero fueron las dos formas que puede
inscribir a mis alumnos tanto desde la
plataforma les dio una clave
y con google classroom esto es punto
número uno de los retos ojalá no haces
ya armadas si quisiera hablar primero mi
clase armada y de repente me decía la
directora yo estoy en tu clase tío
porque no no sé por qué se me quedaron
directivos dijeron mejor como
estudiantes y ya posteriormente les dije
a los niños no se inscriben es muy
sencillo puede entrar con google
nosotros que utilizamos cuentas google
educativas entraron se inscribieron
pusieron en la clave de mi clase que te
dan y todos los alumnos escribieron eso
fue un primer reto que yo tuve un
segundo reto era cómo asignar
actividades porque de un momento yo
decía bueno le pongo palomita al cuadro
y vi que ponerle palomita el cuadro
significaba asignarles todas las
actividades
entonces me tuve que dar cuenta que era
por ejercicios o por actividad que los
podías asignar como más comunes
dosificado exactamente pero ese
aprendizaje
error e aprendizaje y que aquí el chiste
tú como docente es no tenerle miedo 1 y
decirle a los alumnos chispas también
estoy aprendiendo no pasa nada vamos a
aprender juntos y esta es otra parte
motivadora para ellos
eso se levanta magreb
o sea se dan cuenta de que el profesor
generalmente pensamos como alumnos que
el profe lo sabe todo y que si yo como
al hombre me equivoco voy a ser juzgado
pero pues también el chiste es que yo
como profe voy aprendiendo al ritmo de
mis alumnos en ciertas cosas sí por
supuesto entonces esto fue sumamente
importante para para mí y decirles hijos
no pasa nada estamos aprendiendo y vamos
a continuar ese fue otra de las
situaciones
la otra situación como veo mis
actividades bueno aquí es una parte que
me encantó porque no nada más a ti te
van poniendo al alumno y sus tareas y
las actividades que hace sino también te
van poniendo te mandan un reporte y este
reporte te va diciendo el puntaje que
tienen los alumnos qué es lo que van
haciendo y cómo van en cada una de las
actividades
este reporte te llega a través del
correo electrónico lo cual también te
puede servir como una evaluación
continua de lo que estás trabajando y de
tus avances
entonces eso fue reto pero también
incorporar lo que khan academy me está
dando
para incorporar a mi clase
independientemente que yo sabía
humanidades
ok oye y si yo soy una maestra o sea
quedan seis semanas si yo soy una
maestra que apenas me acabo de incluir
hoy decido a partir de este webinar he
sido que yo le voy a entrar al
campeonato pero esto empezó hace un mes
cómo le hago para liberarme en tiempos
eso influye
mira yo creo que más bien es una
dosificación de que veas el programa
primero tu grado las actividades que no
son largas son cortas en duración que
los chicos estén motivados y que puedas
rossi ficar los tiempos para mí que me
quede me me ha servido en el sentido de
las tardes que saben que ellos después
de terminar su tarea escolar es su
premio khan academy poder hacer sus
asignaturas
entonces ha sido totalmente diferente yo
creo que aquí el punto es la
dosificación y lo va a poder lograr ok
perfecto a ver por ahí teníamos otra
bueno la motivación ya la tuvimos cuál
consideras tu que ha sido tu mayor reto
trabajando con khan academy y con con el
campeonato
mi mayor reto es de repente darles la
retroalimentación porque porque muchas
veces como docentes en el aula nos
sentimos hasta presionados y con estrés
porque tenemos que cumplir con un
programa tenemos que cumplir con
actividades que ya se diseñaron desde
las escuelas desde sep desde algo